um hello everyone welcome to the YouTube
hang out I'm really excited today to be
talking about how to use YouTube to
build an audience and Phillip Lopez
reached out to me and he started saying
hey I want to interview you for an info
product that I'm making about YouTube
and building an audience and I said cool
let's do it but let's also do it as a
YouTube hang out so you guys could learn
from it and also learn about what
Phillip is up to and I guess get excited
when his product finally hit so Phillip
welcome aboard and hit me with your
questions all right and I just wanted a
I was gonna welcome people but it's kind
of a different here that's fine well
basically I just wanted a to everybody
to know how many subscribe I mean you
your audience knows but the people that
are going to receive this I want to know
what kind of a achievements you you've
had um I know you can so Phillips like
if you're gonna use this recording for
your info product just start it now like
to start okay hey guys welcome back
whoever you do your intro you run in
your show okay alright sounds good all
right hello and welcome everybody my
name is Phillip Lopez and today we have
an awesome guest on the line with us
this person has achieved some really
really great results when it comes to
building an audience using YouTube and
the last time I checked he had ninety
nine thousand seven hundred subscribers
and 10 billion 357,000 143 views now I
checked that this morning so those
numbers are probably only going up which
is a kind of uh i'm super jealous but
anyhow he started his channel back in
two thousand eight and uh and you just
been able to choose some great results
um I felt compelled to reach out to him
and ask him for an interview he was
gracious enough to do it um what else
and I can learn I can learn from this as
long as well as anybody watching this
anyways our guest today is Evan Evan
Carmichael all the way from Toronto
Canada is that correct yeah you got it
all right and a Blue Jays fan i hear ass
i read up a little bit sir and I thanks
for doing the interview man I really
really appreciate it I really didn't
think you would answer so happy to and
yeah 99,000 something we may we're going
to cross 100,000 subscribers today it
may be while we're doing this interview
that we cross 100,000 we'll see um go
jays go absolutely
and yeah excited to be here happy to be
here whatever questions you have let's
do it alright so let's get right to it
for before we get into any other unique
questions or anything like that I just
want to see what kind of what really got
you into what made you want to start off
on youtube and then how you eventually
got into it what made me want to start
on youtube was I I'm a very visual
learner I liked watching videos as a way
to learn and I found that there wasn't
um there wasn't enough content for my
audience which is entrepreneurs um I
struggled as an entrepreneur when I had
my first business i was making three
hundred dollars a month and like living
off the beans and just you know super
sucking story at the start and i found
that learning from famous entrepreneurs
help me get the motivation and the ideas
to then build my business and have
success with it and I thought I want to
share this with others i want to share
that knowledge that i got with others
and i started by writing and then I
thought you know I love learning through
visual medium so why don't I start
teaching to visual mediums and i created
my camera uh I don't know how many years
ago I want to say six years ago I guess
we can look back to find out it could
help aight i think it's a check your
about page or whatever and said 2008 i
believe so 2008 yet I think that's when
I got when I kind of got the name I
don't know when he actually uploaded the
first video oh really but but around
there right and the first videos were
terrible I think the content was good by
my delivery sucked my performance sucks
but it's been a fun journey to get to
where we are yeah i saw i saw some of
your first videos and you could see how
the i'll just progressively gets better
you know so that's that was pretty cool
i got that's kind of how mine are going
i'm just using a mac mac and a quick
time so hey it's you got to start
somewhere right so that's that's better
than what I started with so it's good
yeah yeah and uh what would you say like
a mime mime this is this interview is
really for people that I just wanted to
start off you know growing an audience
with YouTube so with that being said
what do you think are maybe the least
amount of being somebody said it needs
in order to get started with building
audience on YouTube like let's say maybe
within a week or whatever you think is
reasonable yeah I think people focus on
the wrong things I think people focus on
the technology too much they focus on
what year do I need to have what camera
do any what microphone and none of that
stuff really matters the most important
thing that matters is that you have a
message that will impact people and so
if you're telling your story if you've
learned lessons from your experience
right that that's what people care about
mostly that's how you build an audience
sharing a story passionately because you
want people to learn something from you
you want them not to make mistakes or
you want to entertain them or you want
to show them how to be good at league of
legends or whatever it is the value in
the story itself is the most important
part where I think too many people focus
just on the technology in the gear and
that is not going to save you you know I
could have the best tacking gear but it
won't help your channels grow as much as
you getting better be more comfortable
in front of the camera at having a
compelling story that makes sense that
makes a lot of sense um now with that
being said um people not being technical
enough are there any making tools that
you can recommend for somebody to get
started at least uh yeah I would start
with whatever camera you have and now
that just as I said that the gear
doesn't matter we're talking about the
year but that's okay i can start start
with what you have don't don't wait
until you go save up money to get this
thing whatever it doesn't matter start
with whatever you have you have you have
a cell phone use your phone you have a
webcam use that you have a DSLR use that
point shoot whatever whatever gear you
have I still do videos off of my iPad
this one is off with a webcam right like
you know i have now i have a
videographer who comes with me and and
we film stuff together and he's an
expert he's way better at me and that
helps my channel but if you're just
getting started you don't need that just
start with what you have you know the
most important thing if you're going to
upgrade year would be a microphone this
is my mic but as long as you're in a
kind of quiet ish setting you'll be okay
I still do iPad though I do a weekly
book series where I walk on the street
with my iPad
like this and I use the iPad regular
microphone I don't have anything extra
that I'm adding to it and and those
videos go live on my channel once a week
so you could you could have success with
that just start with what you have the
keys to start because so many people
come up with excuses as to why they
can't start they tell themselves the
story because I don't have this special
camera I can't start just start start
right now and you'll get better every
day d practice yeah that makes a lot of
sense uh um not to something a little
something else a little bit different is
there anything you're doing a
specifically this next week or neck and
a certain you know soon could increase
your subscribership reviews it's a great
question I think every every time that
I've made a major breakthrough in my
channel is because of a selfish interest
I make videos for entrepreneurs and I
make videos that I wish other people had
created so as an example I have a
morning series called ents presso and
that's the combination of entrepreneur
and espresso so it becomes an espresso
and what I wanted was as an entrepreneur
I felt like I needed something in the
morning every day to give me a little
hit you know a little inspiration some
ideas some motivation otherwise I'll
just continue to do the same thing I
need somebody to help push me to do more
and I wish that somebody had put
together a video series with famous
entrepreneurs with successful people who
were sharing their secrets in a quick
little hit that I could start my day
with and nobody had done it right I
think I look really hard and I really
wish somebody else did because I
wouldn't have had to do it that would
have saved me tons of time that's what I
wanted uh and so I created it it was out
of my own selfish need that I made it
and I shared it with other people and it
turns out there's a lot of people like
me who wanted that same thing every
morning and you know thank you to me for
having done all the research to put it
up and so I'm thinking you know for
anybody listening watching if you try to
start a YouTube channel think about what
you feel is missing like what video
would you watch because there's not
enough quality content on this topic and
then go out and create that that's very
true the truth and uh and sometimes
there's content out there that's just
really not that good you could
something and make it a little better um
that's what I got see what I've been
doing but i think im gonna try what
you're saying too so but um um well what
would you say is the most of what does
most of your audience come from there's
a certain social media platform that it
comes from or the mostly our YouTube
organic organic YouTube followers yeah I
don't do any I don't do any paid
advertising I do a little bit of
promotional guess of the videos in
social like when I make a video i posted
to twitter that's about it i'm not
paying for that video to go you know
live on twitter with advertisements or
on youtube it comes most of my traffic
comes from people watching one video and
then watch another and another and
another and another because they like
the content and so that gives somebody
like me who has a large library of may
two thousand videos not all of them are
public but it's a big library that gives
me an advantage because the watching
video they'll finish that they like it
to watch another one maybe they
subscribe and so most of these I get it
from related videos because they finish
one and get another and then I'll get a
lot from search as well from YouTube
organic search and then my subscribers
so it's all it's all organic I've never
spent money to grow my youtube channel
in terms of advertising yes this is like
production quality and stuff but the
promotion side is just organic produce
good stuff keep doing it and you'll get
an audience now that makes a lot of
sense um now one thing I do have to ask
is that it just maybe to get people with
some realistic expectations I don't know
if your your results are necessarily
realistic but I know you probably made
some money from google adsense I mean
yeah mostly I'm talking about google
adsense up some people might think
they're gonna make tons of money out for
there which is possible right but um
what do you think is a realistic point
of view for people that are just
starting out uh the average video will
make 2 dot fifty cents per thousand
views that's the industry average so you
have a thousand views on your video you
will make two dollars and fifty cents us
so you can do the numbers to make a lot
of money you need to get lots and lots
and lots of views right a thousand views
for some people might be a lot but
you're not making a lot of money off of
those
views honestly the bigger opportunity
that I find with the YouTube channel
terms of monetizing it is it the
advertising it's using the attention and
exposure that you get to parlay that
into other deals so if it's consulting
work if its products if it's working
with brands if it's creating a book if
it's leveraging that to make a TV show
all the stuff that comes around the kind
of celebrity that you build up that pays
way more than you will offer your
YouTube channel yeah that's what I
thought but because it's it's really not
as much as some people my claim you make
certain amount of money but it's it's a
humbling experience sometimes when you
they also buried with the advertisers to
so um now one thing I do have to ask is
uh you think that there's a end goal for
you or if there if there is one at all
or is it just constantly find more and
more things yeah my goal is to help a
billion entrepreneurs it fuels me like
entrepreneurs give me energy talking to
you gives me energy I could I could be
with entrepreneurs all day long trying
to help them out and forget that I had
to go to the bathroom or eat lunch it's
just it consumes me I love it and so I'm
a big believer in that you have to
follow your passion follow your flow the
things that get you excited the things
that make you come alive that's where
you need to spend more time because
that's we're going to be able to create
something great and so I've been
fortunate to find this passion of mine
and helping entrepreneurs and as long as
I'm excited by as long as I'm interested
in it then I'm going to do it the things
that I'm working on now is I want to be
able to help people that scale my goal
is impact so YouTube is a great way to
do that because when I make one video
I'm not just helping one person out I'm
helping all the thousand people have
that same question I can learn and be
inspired by the content as well you know
I'm right in the book that again has the
ability to reach a lot of people so all
of the goals that I have now we're
geared towards how can I help thousands
hundreds of thousands millions of
entrepreneurs as opposed to just doing
the one on one on one stuff I started
this by doing email reply somebody would
email me a question 7 i'm having a hard
time with XYZ can you help me out and i
would spend half an hour right now and
you
email with all of my suggestions to
really help them and that's great like
that one person got tremendous advice
and they were thankful but I'm only
helping one person out where tons of
people have that exact same question if
I just turn it into a video I'll be able
to reach a lot more people and we're
lucky that YouTube is such an amazing
platform totally get your message out so
impact man that's my goal I want to have
an impact I want to help entrepreneurs
that's what fuels me every day yeah I
saw on your website you think you you've
gone to a lot 20 million I don't know
that member is outdated or not but
that's a very very excellent goal fairy
and gold you want to call it but but uh
yeah that's that's excellent um now I'm
probably gonna go I'm gonna go into a
little bit of like just rapid-fire
questions uh you take your time it
doesn't have to be rapid I just that's
kind of how I set this up but uh I'll
try to get as many questions out there
as we can um as we can uh so uh if there
is any at all what would you say your
biggest failure was and when you're
trying to trying to build an audience
and maybe how you overcame a specific to
like the youtube channel EG bottomley
i'm talking mostly about YouTube because
I think that's you to be the catalyst
for uh for you know building an audience
that follow you wherever you go got it I
think the biggest failure would be
trying to make videos that I'm not
passionate about because the data looks
good people are talking about this topic
so i should make a video about that too
so i can rank and get a lot of traffic
coming but i'm not an expert in that and
i don't really care about that and every
time I've tried to do a video that that
I thought might be good just in terms of
numbers that I wasn't excited about it
always failed and where where I make
videos that I'm excited by and that
means helping to me they get me riled up
those ones always do way way way better
it makes sense of um is there someone or
something that inspires you get started
with YouTube I think the biggest
inspiration was all those emails that I
was writing that I talked about people
kept writing me emails and I thought
there's got to be a better way to answer
this that combined with the fact that I
was a visual learner and I was
infamous famous stories and I wish
somebody made it in video format because
they didn't want to read as much I
didn't absorb it as as well as i did a
video um so I think those two things
really catapulted my my desire to make
channels a youtube channel i left that
make sense up and they gave me a big
what are you drinking um it's just water
i just have a cup ago from a BBQ place
so I'm just like I got I got my smoothie
my wife makes these smoothies for me
every day I don't know what similar good
you're lucky and i'm looking to get me a
nutribullet so i can make me move these
two mouths but um i'm a bit of a
bookworm myself so uh would you say that
there's any books that that helped out
when you were first starting out on
youtube no not really books for books in
my business yes books for youtube no um
i think there may be some general like
if somebody's trying to start a channel
and they want to turn into a business or
maybe some general books related to
either starting the business or
motivation or inspiration or time
management that kind of stuff that may
help you but in terms of can you learn
about youtube from a book I feel like
the data is so outdated that by the time
it gets the book format you're losing
content just an example I'm writing the
book right now with with penguin Random
House they want it to be submitted by
either october or january and then
they'll be released to the public one
year later so you know the contract i
was writing about YouTube the contents
going to be outdated really quickly and
so I feel like unless it's something
that's produced rapid fire or do
something like you're doing with these
video interviews that you can turn
around really quickly I feel like a lot
of the content would be old really fast
and so I've never turned to a book to
learn anything about YouTube okay good
to know um so what is an average maybe
day or week look like I know you'd make
a lot of videos that that's one thing I
remember seeing you one on Tim Schmoyer
on the video creators chance yes I like
tech where I found you actually and
and I just heard you were pumping out
videos like crazy and I looked at your
channel it was just loaded with them but
what does the average day maybe flash
week look like for you in the context of
the youtube channel I do all my so I
have somebody who does all the research
for me now and I'll review that on
Monday so on Mondays my admitting my run
the business day it's my in the business
day it's my don't care if I shave don't
care how many pajamas day like nobody's
talking to me I'm just getting stuff
done and so in the context of the
YouTube channel it would be reviewing
the research that my researcher has done
and that would be looking at the famous
entrepreneurs whose found the data on
them pulling up the most important
points triggering out the topics i'm
going to be talking about and then
wednesday is my actual filming day will
do three videos every day on the channel
weekends is to every other day there's
three videos on the channel that's a lot
of content that is can't do that
yourself I've got four people now who
are helping me with just my youtube
channel um and then I've got a guy who
comes that I found on craigslist who
comes with his video gear on Wednesday
and we sit down for three to four hours
and I bang out all the videos for the
week and and that takes practice right
like my first videos I would spend days
doing one video now I can do tons of
videos in one day and it's not because
I'm genius from amazing or any of that
it's just practice like anything that
you practice you'll get better at you'll
get better at you'll get better it
becomes becomes almost second nature
becomes a lot easier so by Wednesday all
my videos are recorded send them to my
editor and then every morning I spend
time reviewing the videos that are
coming up for the next day making sure
I'm okay with it any tweaks edits and
then also looking at the comments the
comments I'm a big believer in
responding to your comments the comments
have become overwhelming like hundreds
of comments a day which is amazing but
also insane and so my wife has now
helped me in terms of managing the
comments chill
respond to them and she'll put her name
at the end and then flag the ones that
that I need to see comments feedback
advice haters she's like deal with the
haters so I I get flagged the haters um
yeah so that's a typical week man on top
of running my business and investing in
companies um it's fun but I love it like
I get the energy from YouTube you've
seen your comments every day that's what
drives me knowing that the stuff that
I'm making is having an impact is
helping people in their lives and their
businesses just makes me feel good makes
me want to share with my team he's want
to keep going now wait a minute one
thing I didn't come bubbling they um
something that great work I you cut out
i missed that part sorry uh with the
negative comments I won't touch on that
kind of gotten mixed reviews as to what
youtubers do with them some people say
that they they block them or whatever or
they somatic actually just leave them
there or don't respond to them yes right
the one that deals with those um so yeah
a couple things one I find that if you
are very active in your own community
and you responded to all the comments
that are coming in the positive ones and
hopefully you have mostly positive
comments I mean I have a message of
believe it's inspiring us uplifting
sharing positive stories it's hard to
hate on that right I'm not I'm not sent
a political channel it's not a religious
channel it's hard to hate on a message
but you'll still get people who will
hate but because I'm so active in my
community and responding to all the
comments a lot of times when somebody
does leave a negative one my community
jumps in before I even know it's there
uh and so I love my audience for that
like they're always defending me sending
up for me and you know they want to
ensure that it's a really positive click
for the most part I think my channel is
a massively positive place i'm really
honored i look at a lot of other YouTube
channels and there's so many negative
people and haters where it's a really
positive place like I don't get that
many haters which is which is amazing um
so yeah so one is just dealing you know
deal with your audience
being gauge and they will stand up and
defend you um depending on what the
message is I very rarely delete a
message and I'll Beverly block somebody
the only reason I would ever do it is if
they said something that that hurts
somebody that wasn't me so as an example
I made a thank you video for my
programmer who was a Iranian and I said
thank you so much a deal for being part
of my team really appreciate you I want
to make this video to recognize you and
and I sent it to him and it made it a
live video and for the most part all the
comments are great but one guy said uh
you know you shouldn't hire terrorists
or something right and like you I'm okay
if you attack me because it's a stupid
comment but I don't want him to have to
deal with that because I put him in the
public eye right I put him there he
didn't ask for it and so I would delete
and block that person but anything you
say against me people have said like go
kill yourself Baldy and a bunch of like
negative stuff again it's a tiny tiny
tiny minority of the comments um I tend
to look at when I get a negative comment
is there a teachable lesson here for
somebody else um I don't think that I'm
I don't mind a missin to turn the heater
around my aim is to make them now all of
the sudden be a lover of my content
because I don't think that's going to
happen it's more how I deal with this
can that be a teachable lesson for my
audience and sometimes it is and
sometimes it isn't so if i don't think
it is i'll likely just ignore it i might
even just give it a happy face I might
just thank them for watching just as
like tongue and cheek sometimes I'll
write something like you know I hope you
can contribute more today to the world
then leave your negative comments on
people's channels right like not getting
into the substance of what they wrote
because it's usually there is no
substance yeah um so that's where it's
kind of it it's it's it's a personal
decision each time so so my wife who
looks a lot of the comments she doesn't
know what to do with it and so lose it
for me to handle I'm okay with it like I
don't mom I
I don't mind the meters no that's that's
a great outlook on it manna I'll be
honest sometimes uh sometimes it's
really hard for me not to respond to
that or even it when I got my first
dislike I was like what I didn't even do
anything wrong but you're gonna get
people like that you know so I want any
of my viewers to just be prepared for
any kind of negative stuff because it's
gonna happen probably I think the key is
to do you I'm not a country I'm not a
confrontational guy i don't i don't get
off like i don't get excited by fighting
with people uh and that's you then maybe
that is maybe that's your thing maybe
you like you love fighting with the
haters like bring a guy's and that's
that's your stick and you get a lot of
attention because of it and you like
seeing controversial things um for me I
don't I don't say things that are like
massively controversial but I am me and
so as an example I made a video boat
Warren Buffett and a guy left the
comment and he said why are all
Americans yelling in their videos and
and I didn't if he was talking about me
because i'm not american but Warren
Buffett is and said well who are you
talking about is like the guy you you're
talking like well i'm not american and
and I'm and says is why are you yelling
as they walk I don't know I'm just being
me I'm not trying to yell I'm being Who
I am and he go back they said oh cool go
you i wish i had more confidence on
camera like you do and so it's just you
know understanding that treating them
almost like children like these are
people who often have very little
confidence they're the kids who maybe
didn't get love from their parents and
so they like broke something just to get
attention because negative attention is
better than no attention and just just I
think be don't sink down to their level
don't get into like a mud slinging fast
unless that's who you are and let's like
you thrive off of that because for most
people for me I hate dealing with the
negative like I hate just being negative
in general and so I try to stay positive
as much as possible well that makes that
makes a lot of sense me too i don't
think i would feed either i probably
killing what kind of kill them with
kindness kind of like you said so but
yeah that's actually um no um with
what would you say would be uh maybe the
short term and long term goals a
beginner can you should maybe look for
you know what I mean I think the biggest
thing to start with is creating a
schedule and sticking to it a lot of
people have a goal uh they want to be
successful on YouTube great and they
people will tend to overestimate what
they can get done in a short amount of
time but underestimate what they can do
it a long period so they'll go nutso go
nuts on youtube i'm going to post a
video a day at the other for a month and
see all nobody subscribe to my channel
and i only have 100 views this isn't
working and then they stop where the
value really comes in being consistent
so it's not about making a hundred
videos in one month it's about making a
video every single week getting it out
there continue to improve letting time
build the momentum you getting better
every time and I think it's basically
figuring out a way to stay motivated so
that you are consistently putting out
good content and not worrying about it
being perfect but just worried about
being better than it was last week
because I think too many people quit too
soon because they think they can get
more done faster and they're
disappointed with the results like
that's the world of entrepreneurship not
just youtube you think you can get more
done faster but then you don't realize
that with the time and keep putting out
the videos you start to build up a lot
of steam elementum but you got to be
around for that to happen so you have to
make sure that you keep consistent on
your schedule yeah now it's something a
little bit different uh who would you
say is uh probably the most influential
made one of the most popular person that
you actually have come across just with
uh in your endeavors you know uh with
YouTube yeah but due to be interviewing
or something like that well I mean so
earlier today I did a hangout on my
channel with Stephen Kelly he's a CEO of
sage they do accounting software it's a
billion dollar plus company he has
15,000 employees and I'm doing a
one-on-one interview with him because I
built up an audience right I have
100,000 subscribers and I'm building
momentum and when you start kicking up a
lot of noise in your industry when you
start building momentum and track
you'll start to get people paying
attention to you and wanted to do deals
with you um brands are the first
companies that came to me microsoft and
dell and a weber and intel and telecom
companies and banks because that's my
audience as entrepreneurs so you get to
meet a lot of cool people you get to be
invited to go to a lot of cool events i
got to go to a summit last month in New
Orleans where I'm chatting with the
co-founder of YouTube backstage Chad
Hurley um you know events where Colin
Powell and Deepak Chopra keynoting and
just it and I'm just getting started
like yes I'm hundred thousand cigars but
that's still tiny in the YouTube world
right I want to get 2 million 10 million
want to keep growing that up and so if
you continue to build momentum get that
traction going a lot of opportunities
will open up to you that you never
thought or even possible well that's
excellent but one thing I wanted to
wanted to talk to you about just not
it's actually a little bit out of it
topic is that how did you get started
with salsa because i'm a bit into salsa
myself oh yeah big will from your video
that's that's really cool yeah i'll
spend i'll spend around 20 hours a week
doing salsa I'm a dancer DJ instructor
investor um I got started to impress a
girl um you know what I was in a
long-term relationship five years and
with that with my first girlfriend with
kind of an University my first real
relationship I wanted to go ballroom
dancing and she didn't like it and with
ballroom dancing you can't you can't
really do without a partner so I stopped
and it was made me sad but whatever
leagues the things you do in a
relationship and then when we broke up
like oh I can go dancing no let's go
dancing and I picked up salsa and I went
with a girl um you know that I met
whatever and and to impress her I then
took classes at another school so we
went to our classes I was better and had
all these different moves as well and
and that relationship was super short
didn't last whatever but I love salsa
and so I continued learning and getting
better getting more involved in a local
school eventually investing into it
and becoming a teacher and DJ and
instructor all that stuff so it was one
of those things that I think I think a
lot of people try to plan out their
careers too much if you look at me if I
was if i was looking at what's my next
business opportunity if i were to walk
into a salsa class I have everything
against me you know like I'm 62 I take
huge steps I don't speak Spanish I don't
understand the music I didn't grow up
with it and I'm learning from the
beginning on paper this does not look
like a good business decision for me to
get involved in right like what do I
know about salsa but i loved it i fell
in love with it that's the key and so
I'd encourage everybody watching if
you're making a youtube channel do
something that you're passionate if
you're not good at it yet part of the
videos could be you learning it and
getting better running and picking up
that skill and so it doesn't always have
to make sense on paper it's and there's
between listening to your heart and
listen to your head big decisions out
with the heart and the small ones with
the head oh that's excellent I I know a
little salsa myself and it's it's a good
stress reliever and like you said you
could even make that a challenge so in
your progression as of you getting
better so um I just want to say before
we go just one last question just to
kind of reiterate if someone could take
three things three things away maybe
three lessons away from what we talked
about today what would you think that
would be I would say make videos that
your passion about I would say keep a
consistent schedule and i would say work
on yourself and don't worry about the
gear that make sense there's anything
what's that you think i missed anything
no that was great we've got a bunch of
questions too but we can wrap up your
part before we get to the questions yeah
and uh last thing is a word where can
people find you I know I know where to
find you but where can people go to find
you I know it's pretty simple but still
just to reiterate yeah a bunch of places
easiest thing you just put in Evan
Carmichael into Google and you'll find
me website Twitter YouTube all that
stuff okay I just want to thank you evan
it's been an awesome interview it very
candid and I just really appreciate you
taking the time to do it and I hope
everybody that's
watching this really enjoyed and got
something out of it too thank you very
much happy to help all right it's like
Savannah I appreciate it and you said
we're gonna have other people come in
now yeah people are asking questions so
guys for we've got we've got 19 people
watching live the big gulp from Phillip
there is good I like I bet ah yeah you
guys have questions I've got a little
bit more time before leaving in the chat
there on the side um so let's see what
we got coming on here I'm worried about
the lack of presentation leo I'm worried
about Locker presentation to start up a
YouTube channel so do you have a youtube
channel yourself Phillip you're talking
a little bit about it I Kendall's very
primitive it's called it's actually
called YouTube afraid it's cuz I I
didn't know anything about it about
YouTube I mean I've watched YouTube and
stuff but I don't know anything about
starting up my own channel
but I kind of following a friend of mine
who actually did an interview for this
product as well and he uh you got me
inspired to make my own channel and to
not work focus so much on trying to make
it perfect or anything like that you
know it's just use free stuff I use my
mac and uh and a quick time that's it
that's it into iMovie and that comes in
with my imac and you know what it got
started and looks okay i don't really
spend any money on anything on my
channel yeah i think it's okay to be
here's the thing expect the suck expect
the suck except expect your delivery to
sock your gear to suck your presentation
to suck just expect a sock it's okay
when you learn anything you will suck
that's what happens at the start when
you learning salsa dancing you suck when
you're learning to ride a bike you fall
off right whatever you try to learn at
the start you will suck at so don't try
to be perfect I think too many people
try to be perfect you're not happy that
you're not perfect so you don't release
anything and then you never actually get
started and so that's not the key to
getting started the key to getting
started is actually start and so yes
your presentation will not be as good as
it will be in a year if you keep doing
this you go back on my old videos you go
back to six years ago or whatever my
first date is coming out they suck
compared to what i'm doing now and
that's just natural progression so it's
okay to be worried i'm not saying just
throw up whatever but don't let that
want it to be perfect and in never one
to make a mistake hold you back from
actually doing something right you got
to get it out and be consistent and just
worried about being better than last
week don't worry about being perfect
there's no such thing I still have to
get better you may think my videos are
great but I don't think they are there's
still way more I could get better I I
still watch some of my readers like ah
man why did I say it like that right
yeah fine right even now these hangouts
I just got this webcam uh this is the
first week i'm using this web cam i was
using my mac air up until now to do
these right and it can still get better
i got better lighting whatever is always
helping to improve on as long as it's
better than last week that's the most
important thing thanks elephant who
writes in do you need to have your face
and voice in your videos to have a sec
full channel what do you think i don't i
don't think sizing so well i think it's
important to have your voice at the very
least because at least p I can I mean
you can feel somebody authentic by their
voice even more so with their face you
know um especially if you want people to
follow you somewhere it's good to put
your face out there I think um but you
see some of these gamers on the gamer
channel that never show their face or
anything like that and they got a huge
following so I save anything at least
your voice yeah I think I think the more
personal you can make it the better shot
you have it being successful because
people want to subscribe to you and for
that to happen they have to feel like
they know you and so it's not a
mandatory but um I think the more you
can do it the better and and recognize
that you don't to be perfect in polished
right like what people will like about
you is that you're yourself that's the
most important thing they don't want to
see some polished version of yourself
where you're not sharing your real
opinion and you're you're playing it's
super safe and you're boring right when
you're nervous and we try to be perfect
you're born you not see anything
meaningful that's not what they want
they want to see you and so just get
more comfortable being you you talk
about gamers I oh I play league of
legends I'm in silver for I graduated
this morning the silver for at three
thirty in the morning so I'm proud of
that I subscribe to some gamers and the
ones that I subscribe to I can actually
see them right like you see them in the
bottom corner you see their face i get
done a green screen where behind them or
you see them at the beginning or at the
end you definitely hear their voice so i
don't know what kind of channel you're
doing whoo-hoo but um i would say the
more you can learn to incorporate that
the more likely you'll get subscribers
and just start start small like don't go
it can be super scary to stand in front
of a camera for my first ones i had to
have my assistant or my sister coming
focus the camera leave the room and then
i would come back and do my video
because i couldn't do it in front of
anybody else ya know it's super scary um
but with practice it'll it'll get better
so maybe you start just with the voice a
little
but and then you get more that'll be
easy for you then then you can work on
just a little bit maybe you're just any
extra at the end you set the ending clip
thank you guys so much I'd love to hear
a comment that's all you say right and
then that becomes comfortable and you
just slowly stretch yourself and
suddenly if you look back and see Wow
taking all these steps and I've taken
this giant leap but really just little
steps at a time yeah um Evan uh speaking
of imperfect I just realized my mac is
running out of battery you give you ten
sections I gotta go run and get my court
Oh kind of it that's live you two
friends I'll good yeah I boca we're go
for it i'll continue perfectly okay
O'Neill do you think it's a great idea
to collaborate with other artists like
musicians to help boost my channel but I
want to focus on vlogs and share my
dream as a kid taking on a path from
passion I love collaboration I think
it's one of the easiest ways to grow
your channel is to find people who
already have your target audience and
see if there's a way that you can work
together um I've done some we talked
about Tim Schmoyer earlier on in the
shin the show here I did I did a collab
with Tim talked about YouTube he sent me
some subscribers he was on my channel I
said hit some subscribers I think you
can find people who share your same
vision why have the same impact that you
do then it's a great way to do it I
collaborate with with musicians there's
a guy if you watch my interests Oh
series there's a song that everybody's
talking about um that's pretty cool and
I give him the key made a custom song
for me and I give him a link to his
soundcloud page in the description so
his tons of really creative cool ways um
people there was a guy who was making
pancake art and he wanted to turn me
into a pancake and I said sure I could
I'll put that video up and so he it
wasn't fantastic but it was ok whatever
got a laugh um and so i love i love
doing collaborations and i would
definitely look at people who are
definitely in your niche and the people
who are related to it as well that you
may be able to connect with even this is
a collaboration right yeah right now
this is a collaboration yeah I remember
all I did was I went on facebook and
Evan was kind of in my niche you know
kind of in the nice i wanna i wanna
and I just said hey I love your stuff
yeah really good style I saw you on
video creators uh what would be the best
way to connect to do an interview and he
actually answered I didn't I it was it
was really awesome so I you know will
say yes you might as well try you know
so I mean Phillip is just starting out
his channel bare basics and trying to
learn and get better mai-chan has a
hundred thousand subscribers in my
industry of entrepreneurship I'm one of
the top three channels in terms of
subscriber count and I wrote back and
said hey let's do it and here we are
answering questions so uh collaboration
is a great idea it's just a matter of
reaching out and making your list and
connect with people I love it's a great
idea I keep seeing BTA followed by a
number what does that mean you know what
any of my videos not a live video just
look in the description because I
explained it there is sharing youtube
videos on reddit a good idea I've had no
luck with but you never know what a goal
viral you know it could bring some eyes
on your stuff but um I think it might
work I just haven't personally seen
anything any success from it and I
haven't shared a couple but I don't know
about yourself ah I I could probably do
better job in the promotion because I
don't do any promotion um i have had my
videos go viral as an example on me to
be doing 50 cent he saw it and he shared
it so 50 cent wrote a blog post about it
he put it on his twitter put on his
facebook and the thing blew up which was
awesome i did a video on someone else
that made WorldStarHipHop will star
hiphop I want to say world sup is a cult
WorldStarHipHop so you know how much you
know about hip hop just by that question
I should know more about everything
somebody left a comment like dude you
made worldstar like that I don't know
what you're talking about um I know I
mean I think the biggest challenge for
honestly honestly the biggest challenges
your content isn't good enough like yes
you have to distribute them yes you need
to promote it but if your content is not
good enough people aren't going to share
it right so i would i would spend a
disproportionate
out of my time focused on how to make my
content better and how to improve myself
and you have a better message then worry
as much about the promotion psyche is it
if you do a really good job on your
youtube videos people watch it people
share it will start to get ranked and
the promotion almost takes care of
itself it's always room to do more
always always always without the pick
between focusing on mean getting better
versus focus on promotion I would always
pick on me as much as possible I'm more
interested in gaining audience and
creating the fan base more than money
from YouTube what have you found Phillip
what are you getting like the this
product that you're creating is it about
making money from adsense is it'll build
an audience what are your you've been
fighting from your community well I mean
for me the long long term goal for me is
a is to have a life right I can you know
have time freedom as Tim Ferriss might
say or something like that you know um
so but the way I see it is you just help
somebody if you're so focused on the
money I think I was focused on the money
at first so when I first started in any
kind of internet marketing not just
YouTube um I was focused on the wrong
thing but when I started focusing on
helping people solve a problem so that's
when that's when I started engaging with
people because that's why I think
YouTube is great because your face is
there you're you can really really
relate to people people start to trust
you and uh it's really more about
solving a problem and then the money or
anything like that to me is that's just
gonna be a byproduct of it you know um
so that's my opinion on it and I if the
healthy if I can make money doing
something and make a living doing
something I love and I helping other
people i think that's that's where i'm
at kind of like like how you were saying
about helping a billion entrepreneurs in
the world to me the the money is a
byproduct of all that of being doing
something good you know ya got i think
it's important for youtubers to
understand that we're ahead of the curve
we're ahead of the the dollar spend
curve where the people who are spending
money right now the big corporation
they're starting to get into youtube but
they're still there the old-school
mindset of TV ads and newspaper ads and
magazine ads
it's starting the shift but if you look
at the you look at who are the top 10
celebrities for people who are for
teenagers like seven or eight of the ten
our YouTube stars youtubers are getting
way more book deals YouTube is getting
way more brand deals youtubers are
getting way more opportunity to speak at
events it's rising like you were part of
a trend that is happening and more
dollars are going to be flowing into it
way way way more than just making
Adsense like that's maybe enough to give
you coffee and put something down
towards your rant or whatever but you'll
make you can make tons of money i make
six-figure brand deals because people
want access to my audience right and so
this is this is where you can make a lot
of money from having a powerful audience
and sharing your honest opinions much
more than just trying to rank an SEO for
keywords and driving adsense traffic to
it and I believe to just personally that
you want to do something that you're
proud of that you're happy with that
makes you come alive but just when
you're doing work that you love you feel
better you know like just you bring that
to your relationships or bring that to
your life you I don't understand people
who don't want to do something that
makes them feel good right just I'm
helping somebody right and so just
making videos off of Adsense and
whatever the next hot trend is something
that you don't let you care about might
make you some money but it's not going
to make you big money and most likely
and it's not going to make you guys
something to fill you up and so I I'm on
page with you i would say focus on the
audience and if you do that unexpected
opportunities will come i got brand
deals i got book deals i got radio shows
lots of stuff is happening i never plan
for just because people wanted access to
my audience and so it's scary it's scary
not having a plan it's you want to think
you have it all planned out this is how
i'm going to make money and survive and
you write it all down but it never
happens like your plan it but there is
power attention is to currency so if you
can get people's attention there'll be
tons of different ways to monetize it
yeah you got me excited there who acts
like leo uh GTV this is my first live
show ever very
good awesome here we go the brick is
virginity Philip fine food there you go
two and 12 for Wendy hashtag smoothie
someone absolutely uh hello believe
nation don't be offended when you get a
bad comment it's giving giving them
control you would charge of how you feel
yeah i agree with that today it's a lot
a lot of talks with negative comments uh
what to do when you're not a natural
public speaker what do you think so are
you speaking in your videos yeah you're
like on camera you like the expert the
talking head thought leader right well
I'll start off oh my guess it part of
warm ain't gonna go blow my intro I mean
I have like a little little kinky side I
said you couldn't create the name of my
show and its really really good oh right
now but it'll get better as time goes on
and then I kind of switched from back to
my screen where I show hey you go do
this do that step by step [ __ ] this is
how you do a custom thumbnail it for
free and that's what I took one of my
more popular because that the god yeah
if you can feel somebody you know show
your face and you chose somebody on
screen that's pretty awesome but that's
what I do mostly I've tried [ __ ] head
videos myself and I see a lot of drop
off on that because i'm out i'm not good
enough talking yet quite yet not on
camera at least when i'm off camera I'm
pretty candid but I'm still a little
nervous at times though yeah too many
you someone says I'm not good at public
speaking it's just like saying I don't
know how to speak French like nobody
learns it at the start you pick it up
right like if that's something you don't
you're not born with it you can learn it
you can get better I'd as a skill that
you can continually improve and I
remember my first videos you go back on
my channel I'm in it as a talking head
just for the beginning and the end and
it's super boring because I had a script
and i'll try to remember every single
word on the script and see you see me
like looking up to the left I guess is
right it's probably inverted on here I'm
trying to like think of exactly the
worthy when I don't want to say the
wrong word it's exactly like I wrote it
down even though it was only like maybe
five lines and then at the end again
thank you so much for watching like
Superboy
um because it was trying to be perfect
and and by yes I said the exact right
words it was perfect but the delivery
suck and it's much more about how you
say it in the exact words that you use
and then the rest of my video was me
reading something and then showing
pictures so if it did the video about
Steve Jobs I would write a whole script
out and I would I would sit in front of
a microphone and I would read it and
then I would just show clips about Steve
Jobs on top of it and that's how I
started it was ok and people still look
back in those videos and they still
leave comments and they still give it
thumbs ups like wow it's so bad like
please please watch the new stuff
because it's way way way better uh but
with every video I got better I improved
it became talking head Evan on some of
them and the first ones that I did all
by myself like speaking for two minutes
into the camera was brutal again trying
to memorize then I went to memorizing
three points right here are my three
bits of advice for you and then I would
riff off of those points right I just
try to say something to each other's
points and practice even now when
somebody ask me a question making the
video I'll think about it for a couple
minutes pace around a little bit you
know walk around think about it come up
with generally what I want to say get
excited by and then just boom start
talking um but like if you want to learn
French you practice every day you'll get
really good at French same thing with
public speaking practice get better film
yourself every day make a commitment to
learning it like any other skill and you
will get better oh great ah can I
recommend any software for animation you
do do you do any software for animation
I use I use iMovie so I don't know it
somebody else uses something else I
really don't so yeah I mean I'm the
wrong going to talk to transitions and
titles that's all I did I started with
windows movie maker oh yeah movie maker
and this powerful hey first time I don't
know anything movie makers a great place
to start and then I move the Camtasia
which gives you a little more features
and then I hired an editor that was the
first person I hired was an editor
because that lets me move from
one video a week to 10 videos a week
right I think of one thing you could do
one thing one thing I thought about
doing was uh there's a website called
fiber you can get somebody to edit it
pretty cheap and that that's way more
experience than you are and that's an
option to thank ya you can look into it
yeah for sure I'm use fiber for some
things um yeah so getting the editor
really saved me time and you want to
think about what are you really good at
like I could do everything myself and
then just make one video a week or I
could build a team and I can make 21
videos a week and put them up and let me
focus on what I'm best at which is being
in front of the camera right I could
operate the camera right but my camera
isn't as good as the guy that I hired
the coming in and he goes about lighting
and all of this stuff and I could just
take his files and send them to my
editor and so just the more time I could
spend just in front of the camera doing
what I'm best at the better it is for
everybody the better content you guys
get the more you'll enjoy what we're
doing and so I would try to figure out
are you the best person to do the
editing if you're if you're asking this
question about what software to use my
claim is that
space to help you with it this is kind
of my intuition on it maybe last
question because we're bumping up Sam
rock loyal loyal viewer samra commenting
on all my videos preciate you Sam I
scripted youtube videos are winging it
or combination or is it better just to
prepare the content so you know you
won't be stuck for something to say I
basically just answered that what do you
do for my videos I sometimes I do use a
script but I kind of go out I kind of
use it just for like a point of
reference you know and then I realized
I'm being absolutely robotic when I'm
like this is why you should do you know
so then I just kind of go I'm trying to
branch out from there and just try to be
myself cause really I'm just a goofball
I think that's if I can get a little bit
more into that but that's probably a
little more natural but for now I'm
still kind of going off script for the
most part I'm branching away from that
because I i like watching video where a
guy just it doesn't look like they're
reading from the script I just kind of I
know you need it for just to remember
some things that I remember everything
but I say more of a point of reference
and actually just read enough that's
just me yeah I think you would have a
lot more success if you incorporated
your goofball pneus into your videos
more right like I'm not I'm not super
goofball but i'll do some fun things on
some of my videos um my my like magic is
passion I'm passionate when I get
excited about something now go on a rant
people connected that really well that's
my superpower so the more I leverage
that the more success my channel has
more subscribers to get the more it
impacts people I you if it's being a
goofball that's another way to teach
right like through funny through
entertaining that's a great way for
people to teach to instead of being um
you know right now you might be nervous
you might be getting used to be in front
of the camera not being the same person
you are in real life um I'm now I'm like
this in real life right like somebody
asking these questions I'll get excited
this is how I'll answer it I'm just
being me and it took a lot of videos to
get here but I think if you were to do
that for all you guys listening like
what's special about your personality
what do you love to do what's your
superpower
you could bring when you can start
incorporating that even a little bit
into your channel you'll start to have
more fun and also get a lot more results
yeah cool bumping up against a clock I
know there's more questions I'm really
sorry guys we extended this already
beyond what I thought it would go so
that's okay but I gotta run to a meeting
uh Phillip for those of for the audience
who want to learn more about you follow
you on YouTube or Twitter what's the
best way to reach out to you uh my
youtube channel is uh youtubing for
idiots exactly the G at the end and with
the number four and then idiots and then
uh my twitter handle is niches it's cuz
it's my blog name my blog it's niches be
crazy it 82 that's when I was born and
then I also have my website which is
WWE's be crazy calm cool maybe if you
want to shoot me an email with all of
those things i will add it to the
description below so people can can see
that too that's great i will do so yeah
all right thank you guys for watching
Thank You Philip for the time continue
to believe and we'll see you soon thank
you so much appreciated
you